OF SOME OF THE CHILLING AND
NEWLY REVEALED IMAGES FROM
BUCHA.
HERE IN KYIV I SPOKE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN BUCHA EARLIER WITH
U.N. SECRETARY GENERAL ANTONIO
GUTTIEREZ.
HE SAT DOWN WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN
TO CREATE HUMANITARIAN
CORRIDORS.
THIS WAS HIS FIRST AND ONLY
ENGLISH LANGUAGE MEETING SINCE
THAT MEETING WITH VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
WERE YOU SATISFIED WITH WHAT YOU
HEARD FROM VLADIMIR PUTIN
YESTERDAY?
>> I THINK IT WAS A VERY USEFUL
MEETING.
FIRST OF ALL, IT WAS POSSIBLE TO
TELL THE SAME THINGS TO
PRESIDENT PUTIN THE SAME THINGS
I SAY HERE IN NEW YORK OR HERE
IN KYIV, WHICH IS THE RUSSIAN
INVASION IS AGAINST THE CHARTER
OF THE UNITED NATIONS.
IT'S A VIOLATION OF THE
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY OF UKRAINE
AND END IT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND AT THE SAME TIME
OUR CONCERNS ABOUT VIOLATIONS OF
INTERNATIONAL LAW, HUMAN RIGHTS
LAW, POSSIBILITY OF WAR CRIMES.
SO I COULD EXPRESS THESE
CONCERNS VERY CLEARLY, VERY
OPENLY AND AT THE SAME TIME A
VERY SERIOUS DISCUSSION ON OUR
WEEKEND, MY DRAMATIC SITUATIONS.
I CONCENTRATED MY EFFORTS INITA
CORRIDORS AND THE CIVILIANS
TRAPPED IN THE STEEL FACTORY IN
MARIUPOL.
>> THERE MAY BE AS MANY AS 1,000
CIVILIANS IN THERE AT LAST
COUNT.
THE HUMANITARIAN CORRIDORS, IT
HAS BEEN VERY FRUSTRATING FOR
UKRAINIANS TRYING TO GET OUT.
RUSSIA SAYS THE CORRIDORS ARE
OPEN AND YET THE UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS SAY THEY CONTINUE TO
BOMB OR THE CORRIDORS MAY BE
OPEN BUT ONLY HEADING TO RUSSIA.
DO YOU BELIEVE VLADIMIR PUTIN
WOULD ALLOW CIVILIANS TO LEAVE
TO UKRAINE?
>> LET'S BE CLEAR, PRESIDENT
PUTIN AGREED WITH ME IN
PRINCIPLE THAT WE WOULD HAVE
WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE U.N. AND
THE SUPPORT OF THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMITTEE OF THE RED CROSS, THAT
WE WOULD HAVE EVACUATION OF
THOSE CIVILIANS INTO THE
TERRITORY CONTROLLED BY THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT AND WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THE DETAILS.
AT THE PRESENT MOMENT THEY ARE
BEING DISCUSSED IN MOSCOW
BETWEEN THE MINISTRY OF DEFENSE
AND OUR PEOPLE.
WE ARE ALSO IN CONTACT WITH THE
GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE TO SEE IF
WE CAN HAVE A SITUATION IN WHICH
NOBODY CAN BLAME THE OTHER SIDE
FOR THINGS NOT HAPPENING.
>> WHEN SOME PEOPLE LOOK AT U.N.
AND ARE FRUSTRATED THAT ON THE
SECURITY COUNCIL RUSSIA
OBVIOUSLY HAS A VETO AND CAN
STOP ANYTHING FROM THE SECURITY
COUNCIL REALLY RULING ON WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE WHO SAY
THAT THE U.N. CAN'T BE EFFECTIVE
BECAUSE OF THAT?
>> WELL, U.N. IS NOT ONLY THE
SECURITY COUNCIL.
THE GENERAL ASSEMBLY WAS CLEAR
IN ITS POSITIONS AND WE HAVE
1,400 STAFF IN UKRAINE.
WE ALREADY HAVE DIFFERENT
HUMANITARIAN AID TO 7 MILLION
UKRAINIANS.
ONE OF THE REASONS FOR MY VISIT
IS TO ORGANIZE THINGS IN ORDER
TO SCALE UP OUR ACTION AND TO BE
ABLE TO DO MUCH MORE FOR THE
UKRAINIANS HAVING SUCH DRAMATIC
CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> AS FOR NOW YOUR SITES ARE
TRYING TO FOCUS ON WHAT YOU
THINK MAY BE ACHIEVABLE JUST IN
TERMS OF GETTING CIVILIANS OUT
OF DESPERATE SITUATIONS AS
OPPOSED TO A MULTI-NATIONAL
MEETING TO TRY TO ACTUALLY END
THE WAR?
>> I MEAN, THE WAR WILL NOT END
WITH MEETINGS.
THE WAR WILL END WHEN THE
RUSSIAN FEDERATION DECIDES TO
END IT AND WHEN THERE IS A
SERIOUS POLITICAL AGREEMENT.
WE CAN HAVE ALL MEETINGS BUT
THAT IS NOT WHAT WILL END THE
WARS.
>> WHAT ROLE IS THE U.N. PLAYING
IN TERMS OF WAR CRIMES
INVESTIGATIONS ON THE GROUND?
YESTERDAY VLADIMIR PUTIN AFTER
YOUR MEETING CONTINUED TO SAY
THINGS WHICH WERE NOT TRUE
SAYING THAT THE BODIES THAT WERE
FOUND IN BUCHA WAS A PROVOCATION
AND THAT'S A REASON WHY
NEGOTIATIONS FAILED BECAUSE OF
THESE FALSE IMAGES OF DEAD
PEOPLE WHEN IT'S CLEAR RUSSIAN
TROOPS KILLED CIVILIANS IN
BUCHA.
>> SINCE THE VERY FIRST MOMENT I
SAID WE NEED AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION.
WE NEED TO HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY.
I MUST SAY, I AM VERY HOPEFUL
THAT THE INTERNATIONAL
PROSECUTOR IS HERE, THAT THEY
ARE INVESTIGATING.
THAT IS THE RIGHT WAY TO DO
THINGS.
THERE IS ALSO A GROUP OF THREE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
INQUIRY OF HUMAN RIGHTS COUNCIL.
THERE ARE MONITORS AND THE
OFFICE OF HUMAN RIGHTS HIGH
COMMISSIONER AND I HOPE THAT THE
TRUTH WILL BE FULLY ESTABLISHED
AND THAT RESPONSIBILITIES CAN BE
THERE AND ACCOUNTABILITY CAN BE
EFFECTIVE.
>> FINALLY, GENERAL MILLI IN THE
UNITED STATES YESTERDAY SAID THE
GLOBAL ORDER THAT'S BEEN HELD
TOGETHER SINCE WORLD WAR II IS
UNDER THREAT IF RUSSIA IS
ALLOWED TO BE VICTORIOUS.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT, THAT
INTERNATIONAL SECURITY IS AT
THREAT HERE?
>> INTERNATIONAL ORDER FOR ME IS
ESSENTIALLY THE CHARTER AND
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
THERE WAS A VIOLATION OF THE
CHARTIER AND INTERNATIONAL LAW.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ESTABLISH THE PRINCIPLES OF THE
CHARTER AND TO MAKE
INTERNATIONAL LAW SOMETHING
EVERYBODY IS FORCED TO ABIDE BY.
>> JUST ONE MORE QUESTION.
WHEN YOU TALK TO VLADIMIR PUTIN,
DO YOU USE THE WORD WAR?
DO YOU USE THE WORD INVASION?
>> I SAY THE SAME THINGS I SAY
IN MOSCOW, KYIV, AND NEW YORK.
THAT IS HOW THE UNITED NATIONS
CAN BE CREDIBLE.
IF WE GO TO EACH PLACE AND SAY
WHATEVER PEOPLE LIKE TO HEAR IN
THAT PLACE, WE WILL COMPLETELY
LOSE CREDIBILITY.
>> IT WAS LAVROV THAT RAISED THE
SPECTER OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS BEING
USED.
HOW BIG OF A CONCERN IS THAT FOR
YOU?
>> IT IS A CONCERN.
I'M SURE THE WORLD WILL AVOID
THAT RISK.
I MEAN, IT WOULD